[Music]
in November 1884 the New York Times ran
a pretty interesting story an astronomer
known only by the name Arendt claimed to
have discovered a cubic planet just
beyond the orbit of Neptune less than
100 years later another discovery was
made this time by a man who not only
named the planet but who also had maps
and sketches of its alien life-forms
coincidence crazy or our cubic planets
possible could humans live on a cubic
world how would our climate change
how would gravity be affected could we
stand it this is what if and here's what
would happen if the earth was a cube all
planets are round but have you ever
wondered why let's go back in time say
four and a half billion years ago a big
cloud of gas and dust called a nebula
collapsed to form a hot star which
through its gravitational pull attracted
all nearby matter and formed a large
rotating disc around its center after
more than just a few collisions the
matter orbiting the young Sun eventually
grew into massive bodies with strong
gravitational centres they formed
planets inside any given planet gravity
pulls equally from all sides towards its
center this accounts for their spherical
shape so because the earth we live on is
a sphere and its gravitational pull is
the same wherever you go
it means that as long as you're on a
flat surface you'll be standing straight
and tall but what do you think happens
when you skewed the distribution of
gravity so you want to live life on the
edge
then pick a side the earth has six faces
now but sadly none of them are any fun
that's because anywhere you go is going
to feel like you're climbing up a steep
hill on the cubed earth gravity is
strongest at the center of each of its
phases so the further you are away from
the center the more you'll feel it's
poem hope you didn't take standing tall
for granted the landscape along the
Earth's edges would be rocky and barren
since all the water would be pooled at
the center of each face and the
atmospheric quality along the Earth's
edges and corners would be too thin to
support life or non-existent
we'll come back to that later the new
climate would depend on how the Earth
rotates if our cubed planet rotated on
an axis through two of its phases then
the climate would be kind of how it is
right now on earth only more extreme the
top and bottom faces would be polar
while the remaining four sides would
enjoy an equatorial climate however if
the earth was a cube that rotated
through its corners then each side would
have a temperate climate you could say
goodbye to extreme temperatures and
precipitation sadly that means saying
goodbye to your equatorial fantasy world
- on the plus side you might just be
able to walk into outer space
since our atmosphere is held down by
gravity and since gravity is not pulling
from the center of each of Earth's faces
it means that the atmosphere would be
thicker where gravity is strongest and
thinner towards the edges what's more if
the cubic earth had the same volume as a
rounded world today
then it's sharp steep corners would
actually poke out beyond our atmosphere
these areas would be unprotected and
therefore uninhabitable but who says he
couldn't rent a space suit and stand on
top of the world and outside of it at
the same time would you do it what else
could you do on a cubic planet could you
adapt what would we call ourselves on
this six-sided earth Cubist's Cubans
will never find out and that's probably
for the best
but we'll keep trying things out as long
as you're curious new episodes of
what-if are coming soon so be there or
be square